[Music]
michelle williams is pregnant with her
third child
she confirms the news in a recent
interview calling it quote totally
joyous
i think that being a mom has helped me
understand life you know there's no
there's no aspect
that goes untouched by becoming a parent
so it's changed you know it's not just
changed one thing for me it's changed
everything for me it's the second child
for her and husband thomas kell
following the birth of sun heart during
the pandemic the 41 year old actress
tells variety quote as the years go on
you sort of wonder what they might hold
for you or not hold for you it's
exciting to discover that something you
want again and again is available one
more time
that good fortune is not lost on me or
my family
[Music]
michelle and thomas tied the knot in
2020 the two worked together on the tv
series fosse verdin we have the
opportunity to make something very
special
she's also mother to 16 year old
daughter matilda and her father is the
late actor heath ledger while navigating
the spotlight michelle tends to be
private when it comes to her personal
life but she has opened up to e.t about
the life-changing impact of being a mom
i can't remember like a me before
motherhood um
it is so
totally
um my
identity
that
it's in every thought and every action
that i take is
um
well what would this mean
even things that are sort of intangible
you know things that are don't seem
directly related to motherhood because i
think the really interesting thing about
becoming a mother is that when you
become a mother you become every mother
it is
you know a mother's love is garden
variety it's
it's not special the way i love my
daughter is not more special than the
way that another mother loves her child
but there's nothing stronger in the past
there's just nothing stronger it's this
unbreakable umbilical connection that
you just
just can't shake
[Music]